this is very technical but it's quite
deep so when i need to it's kind of like
a mask and i have my cover mask and then
i have the hat
but now i've just sold myself out
because if you if you ever see this hat
it's not me
g'day gq i'm jacob belordi and these are
my 10 essentials
[Music]
had a watch with me
you know for as long as i can remember
since i was small but it's not so much
sort of like the time keeping aspect i
like the weight of it and i like the way
that it feels it helps me kind of not
feel naked i suppose this watch is from
tag it's the monaco i got this just
recently in monaco this is the dark lord
steve mcqueen wore the original monaco
with the blue face of this back in the
day kind of feels like a cool piece of
history to have then i you know i found
out there's pictures online of stanley
kubrick on the set of clockwork orange
with a monaco as well so it kind of has
a rich cinematic history which is
you know it's exciting
[Music]
this is a recent essential a deck of
cards is a recent essential to me i have
never understood cards my whole life i
could never learn card games i didn't
have the patience for them i was reading
val kilmer's book of poetry someone at
the start it might even share
i think it might have been share cher
said he had this poker chip that he
would flick between his fingers and she
asked him like why are you always
flicking the poker chip and he said i
don't know what i'm gonna need it and
then his film with his came out and it
cut to a scene and he was sitting at the
table for no reason flicking the poker
chip and she was like
and so i was like you know what i don't
know anything about cards i don't know
how to handle them i don't know how to
shuffle but i was like i want to have a
you know i want to have a poker chip i
want to be able to just pull out
something sometime whether it's a deck
of cards i don't know i'll learn a
little
blackjack
i'll learn a little
play this game called slapjack it's a
high-stakes game of snap
i don't play for money i play for the
thrill of it
[Music]
this next thing is um
it's not specifically always
this um you know a cigarette case
i don't smoke this has post-it notes in
it i consider it like a totem and i
always carry one of these
especially when i'm creating a character
it's something that kind of
centers the character for me or gives me
a base you know i have it in my pocket
all the time when i'm shooting and this
was
playing um
a character in the film i just shot
called he went that way and it was set
in the late 1950s and he was this young
kid who got discharged from the army and
went on a spree killing sort of across
america and he smoked a lot of
cigarettes so i found this
on etsy which is kind of this period
cigarette case and i had this on me the
whole time i was filming i don't know it
sounds a little pretentious but this is
like has the soul of the character in
and then i can put it to the side when i
go home the first films i ever made i
had a this uh this silver necklace and
the thing is i have to i have to buy it
myself and it's kind of uh i wouldn't
say ocd because it feels more spiritual
than that but it you know i guess it
converges on
that kind of idea
i have a lot of different cameras but
this camera is a medium format
rolleiflex this particular camera is
special
because
there's this great documentary called i
think it's called i am heath ledger it's
one of the cameras that he uses so this
is definitely one of my most valuable
cameras to me i think the lens is glass
and you know the pictures are crisp and
there's just something kind of timeless
there's a very satisfying feeling that
comes from hearing the shadow the main
thing
that i you know that i try to shoot is
the people around me and the things that
are happening around me because i feel a
lot of the time when i first came to uh
to hollywood you know so much of it is
you wouldn't believe it so for me it's
just kind of about catching all these
memories and moments so that you know
maybe one day i'll just sit in a big
house alone and i'll just
flick through them all and i'll have you
know i'll have them all there you know
it'll be like they're all with me i
think i mean i've already felt the
effect it would have thousands of
printed photos at home in boxes
you know and every now and then you'll
just go through the box and it's just
like you can smell the room you're in
you can hear the people speaking you can
feel
the moment you know what was going on
around you in that time you know
that's like it's kind of magic
[Music]
my next essential is uh
fairly simple it's just a cap just a
black cap this particular cap is from um
it's from left bank books which is a
little bookstore in new york this is
very technical but it's quite deep so
when i need to it's kind of like a mask
you know when i have my cover mask and
then i have the hat
but now i've just sold myself out
because if you if you ever see this hat
it's not me
somebody else that bought the hat from
this tiny little bookstore you know when
superheroes in the superhero films are
like
being regular people
and it's like chris evans in a bomber
jacket with like the most standard
sunglasses you've ever seen and a black
cap i think that was the goal it's like
when i go outside i'm like i'm out in
public like you know i'm not saying i'm
a superhero out in public at all i think
it was just that like
it's kind of like witness protection so
you know what i mean
[Music]
this next item is a uh is a tote bag
somehow even if they look small
it's kind of like hermione's bag um you
know in harry potter and she just like
pulls a [ __ ] pulls a tent out of it
you know it's kind of like that you just
like keep digging and you will find
everything you've ever lost
in this bag
i have too many tote bags
tote bags also expensive now i got one
at an art gallery the other day it cost
54 but i didn't
yes i paid for it because i didn't know
at the time and then they were like
that'd be 54 and i can't really i just
get so nervous i'm like of course it
would be yeah i'll definitely pay for
that that sounds about right
it's ridiculous you know i was too
nervous to be like for a tote bag
ah this one did not cost that much
like i don't even wear that one because
i'm like disgusted with myself
[Music]
i do always always have this with me
everywhere i go
this here is a little traveler's notepad
this is just you know personal thoughts
it's by my bed when i fall asleep in
case you know i have a dream or
something like that my theory is with
having so many books on me all the time
is you never know when you're going to
end up in a hospital waiting room which
sounds dark but the amount of times that
i have ended up in a hospital waiting
room for some ridiculous thing and i
have to wait like eight hours and you
have nothing to do
and you know i don't like sitting on my
phone
so the theory behind it is that you
never know when you're going to be in a
hospital waiting room this is a
set of plays by tennessee williams for
if i'm in the mood for that
and then i also like to have
like fiction
on me this is just another personal
notepad that i've had for a little while
this is a workbook a journal for the
character i'm about to play in this this
film i'm doing and i found this recently
in madrid
this kind of adam and eve
notepad and it kind of
something about it felt like the movie
to me so
this is in my bag now all the time as
well i hate to be without things like uh
because then the ideas and the thoughts
just disappear
you know i don't want to miss anything i
think i underlined something the other
day conversation should be like juggling
up go the balls and the plates up and
over in and out good solid objects that
glitter in the footlights and fall with
the bang if you miss them
i i like that description of a
conversation
[Music]
kind of speaks for itself it's tasty
keeps your breath fresh and when i feel
uncomfortable in social situations you
know you look busy if you're chewing you
know you don't look like you're just
standing in space awkwardly great social
tool
this is the only pack of gum that i can
find but i would say that i'm a five gum
guy you know those massive commercials
that they used to do and it's like this
is what chewing five gum feels like this
ridiculously
physical experience that's my gum for
sure
[Music]
my next essential is a lamy fountain pen
i didn't much like being at school and i
found it kind of boring i think i found
ellie on like by
going out and buying the stationery that
i wanted and riding with like you know
stuff that was different to what
everyone else had it helped me stay
interested
in what was happening i've gotten to a
point where i really can't do
script work or anything without one i
can't just do it with you know a regular
bic pen these are the refills
of the ink and this goes with um
this is a script binder that my dear
friend just gave me recently and it's
kind of like the hat i've been looking
for
for the perfect kind of leather bound
script for
for the longest time and this one kind
of just fell in my lap which i'm
incredibly grateful for usually you
bring things to people's houses when
they're throwing a dinner and he sort of
came out of the room and he just kind of
threw it on my lap and he goes i think
you need this
[Music]
this next essential is a pack of uh
watercolors i read this book it was
about like this fascist sculptor but it
was illustrated by um dali
and there were these illustrations that
had just the most beautiful watercolors
in them and i think i bought this
immediately after
with the idea that i have no idea how to
do watercolors but in sort of those
journals and stuff if i ever get bored
if i do it for the next
you know however many years
maybe i'll like have nice paintings
i love the way the colors look when they
all start to bleed
like this
you know and it makes me look way more
serious than i am when you see this
[Music]
my next essential is a uh
a bandana or a face covering this was
before
before covered this like the hat i
searched for the perfect bandana it
needed to be old but not you know like
super used and gross
and i found this in paris it's also fun
to play with you know if you get nervous
and also my friend alex fitzallen taught
me something if you don't have a belt
you can put this through the belt loops
and then you tie it in a knot
and it pulls the the pants together so
if you're ever without a belt get a
bandana
[Music]
my next essential couldn't be here
because she has a very busy schedule but
it's my dog leila she's a one and a half
year old golden retriever she speaks
about
500 words of english she's a genius she
feels shame she feels happiness people
say that dogs don't smile and if they
smile they're in pain but this dog
literally has dimples
when you wake up in the morning and you
say good morning julie give her a little
you know a little thing she comes and
she wiggles up and her face curls up in
the corners she's my best friend she's
my comfort aunt i run lines with her
that dog's my rock she's so special to
me um
yeah she really is not i don't know what
a deal is i think she might be like an
alien or something because she's um
she's in touch she really is thank you
for watching and listen to me talk about
my stuff i appreciate it and
cheers